a funeral is under way for a police
officer in Italy allegedly murdered by
two American teenagers Mario Churchill
Arreaga was stabbed to death Friday in
Rome the two teens could both face life
in prison if convicted Seth Doane is
outside Naples Italy where mourners are
paying their respects to the officer
Seth what's the mood there mourners have
filled the streets here and only adding
to the emotion of this day is that the
officer who was killed was married in
this very same church just about a month
and a half ago the church was not big
enough for the crowd gathered today for
the funeral of Mario Churchill Arreaga a
vice brigadier in Italy's Carabinieri
Police Force my friend Mario was a good
person town mayor said he dedicated his
life to the service of the weakest
church eller Drago was stabbed to death
on a Rome Street an Italian law
enforcement says the two American
teenagers Finnegan Lee elder and Gabriel
Christian Natale orth confessed to being
involved this all started early Friday
morning when Italian police say the
Americans stole a backpack belonging to
an Italian man which included his cell
phone the man called the phone and the
Americans demanded a gram of cocaine and
a hundred euros to give the bag back
they set up a meeting point here and the
Italian man tipped off the Carabinieri
elder pulled out a knife according to
the arrest warrant and stabbed the
officer multiple times
Natalia orth says he did not see the
knife but in Italy someone can be
charged for murder if they were involved
even if they didn't carry out the
killing the pair had been schoolmates in
the Bay Area where teachers and students
have said they were troubled and had
disciplinary issues a picture of Natalia
you're blindfolded in the Carabinieri
station triggered questions about the
treatment of the teens though Rome's
Attorney General says the interrogation
was free of duress there is no place in
any criminal justice system for a
suspect to be blindfolded
that image of the blindfold is already
drawing comparisons to the case of
Amanda Knox who says she was mistreated
by Italian police during questioning
this case is likely to stretch on for
years CBS News has reached out to both
families and on Sunday the elder family
issued a statement which said they had
not had contact with their son since
Friday that they had been in touch with
the US State Department which had not
had access to him Michelle all right
Seth Doane in Italy thank you